hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast parathyroidism hypo hyper what
is normal really
i am judy o'rourke of la roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by diasoren for over
40 years deosorin has been developing
producing and marketing reagent kits for
in vitro diagnostics worldwide
with their most recent acquisition of
the nordia group diasoren gains access
to the nucleic acid isolation and cell
separation markets its line of products
used by diagnostic laboratories can meet
the needs of many clinical areas for
more information please visit
www.deosorin.com
we have a few important announcements
before you begin this webcast is
designed to be interactive we encourage
you to ask questions during the event
you can submit questions by typing them
in the q a box which can be found by
clicking on the green q a button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problem through
the green q a button lower left
i would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr d c parker rau
dr rau is the section head of bone and
mineral metabolism and director of the
bone and mineral research laboratory at
the henry ford hospital in detroit
michigan
this is a position he has held
continuously since 1995.
his lab is the best bone histone
morphometry lab in the state and one of
the best in the country
under his direction the lab has been
conducting both basic and clinical
research and published extensively on
the pathogenesis of bone fragility
age-related bone loss mechanism of
atypical fractures role of vitamin d and
parathyroid adenomas size and disease
expression
and on parathyroid tumor genesis
dr rao has more than 100 peer-reviewed
papers 100 symposium proceedings
abstracts and letters to the editor and
10 book chapters
he's a founding member of the indian
society of bone and mineral research
which he helped launch in 1997.
dr rao has received a number of awards
including the willard o thompson
traveling scholar award from the
american college of physicians in 1986
and the boy frame award from the
american society for bone and mineral
research in 1999.
he is a fellow of the american college
of physicians facp and the american
association of clinical endocrinologists
face
hello good morning good afternoon and
good night depending upon where you are
in the world
many thanks for all of you joining today
i'll be discussing unparalleled
functional states how to define and how
to assess
these are my disclosures i have an nih
grant lilly and diazo in research grants
i'm on speakers bureau of the lilly
company i served as the dsmb member for
the nps pharmaceuticals
however i will not be discussing any
off-label or investigational use in this
presentation
i do have a financial relationship to
disclose that is i serve on the advisory
board for dinosaur and incorporated
i receive an honorarium for from
diocerine to provide this presentation
however i will be donating the
honorarium to my education research fund
the objectives of today's presentation
is to discuss briefly on physiologic and
measurement considerations role of
parathyroid hormone in normal human
physiology
measuring and interpreting serum pth
levels
assessing the altered parathyroid
function whether it be genetic sporadic
acquired indeterminate or unknown
whether it is hyper hypo or in between
i will present if time permits some
clinical examples to highlight the
points about that i just discussed
however i will not be discussing
management strategies since there are
clinicians as well as non-clinicians but
there will be an ample time for us as in
during question answer time
let me first begin by speak talking to
you about role of purified hormone in
normal human physiology
it is a bit of a busy slide but is an
important slide that i want to highlight
several points
first
parathyroid hormone has three target
organs the kidney
the bone
and the intestinal tract why are the
calcium absorption
it increases 125 dihydroxy vitamin d
level in the kidney so that it increases
the calcium absorption
and that's an important three target
organs
the other highlight highlight that i
want to make is that both paraffin
hormone and parathyroid hormone related
peptide share more or is the same
receptor
however the affinity for the parathyroid
hormone receptor is much greater for pth
than it is for pthrp because of the
homology between the pthrp molecule and
pts the receptor behaves similarly
the downstream biochemical abnormalities
either by pth or pthrp are similar but
nevertheless not identical and i will
not be discussing on pthrp today except
to make a couple of points as i related
to you now
this slide illustrates the importance of
the
reciprocal relationship between the
calcium and parathyroid hormone
although reference ranges for calcium
and pth are given
widely but within individual calcium
variation is much smaller compared to
between individuals for example in the
normal healthy population the reference
range is 8.5 to 10.5 depending upon your
laboratory
but within individual the serum calcium
varies only
0.5 milligrams per deciliter
and therefore most of the people will
lie in this small triangle rectangle
where the pth calcium relationship is
tightly regulated
the well-known actions of path are
hormone that it increases renal
phosphate excretion by inhibiting
tibial reabsorption of phosphate
it increases renal tubular reabsorption
of calcium increases bone resorption and
of course it increases intestinal
calcium absorption by a stimulation of
125 dihydrox vitamin d
in the kidney and possibly in the target
organs
pth also has effects on a wide variety
of target tissues the well-established
and most steady target organs are kidney
bone and indirectly intestinal tract but
there are several repetitive roles for
parathyroid hormone and vascular smooth
muscle perhaps related to hypertension
in hyperparathyroid states it has an
effect on cardiac myocyte perhaps
related to cardiovascular events that
has been reported in patients with
overactive parathyroid gland
and the brain effect may be present
because some people do have
neuropsychiatric manifestations whether
it is purely calcium or pts relate is
debatable nevertheless it's an important
action of the parathyroid hormone on
brain
pth measurements i'm going to turn to
the pth measurements they have taken
there is a history as well as the
evolution
the best known pth action that was
measured early on before the radiomina
essays became available in the early
seventies was the effect on
serial phosphate threshold or trp or
tmpgfr
later on the biologically active
compound nephrogenous cyclic kmp which
is an effect of pth on kidney was used
because earlier parathyroid hormone
assays contained
carboxy terminal assays which were
having a longer half-life and were
affected by the kidney function it was
felt that nephrogenous cyclic mp could
provide more direct effect of the
biologic action of the intact
parathyroid hormone
but soon as the we improved our assays
from c terminal to mid molecule to
intact assays the nephrogenous cyclic
amp has become more or less an extinct
currently we have several interact rias
which i will discuss briefly when we are
talking about the parathyroid
function
they have gone from radioamino acids to
immunoradiometric acids and
chemiluminous anti-assays and
fluorometric acids
including the sandwich assays more
recently biointact pth has been used in
certain situations where the circulating
parathyroid hormone can be
present in several forms
this picture illustrates the
evolution of our assays as you can see
originally we started with the carboxy
terminal assays then we went to the mid
molecule assays
however most of the biologic activity
resides in the first 1 to 34 amino acids
and therefore attempts have been made to
have the sandwich acids which included
the intact assays as shown here
and then more recently more specific
assays were done because the cleavage
can occur either at the sixth amino acid
or at the 17 amino acid uh at which
location there is a serine amino acid
which can phosphorylate and because of
the
several molecules circulating in the
blood the
recent intact assays have become more
and more specific the epitopes are
developed in the first six amino acids
and there's a circulating compound
of amino acid sequence 7 to 83 which may
not be simply biologically active but
interfere and on the right is shown
is the table that shows that most of the
circulating hormone 92 percent is the
intact hormone
so we have evoluted from carboxy
terminal to intact to biointact
i want to spend a few minutes on the
relationship between the pth and vitamin
d level as you know the 25 hydroxy
vitamin d is the best available index of
vitamin d nutrition there has been some
debate about whether pth reference range
should reflect the vitamin d nutritional
status and as you can see in this
study that was done back in 1995 there's
a curvilinear relationship between
powerful hormone level
on the y-axis and the 25 hydroxy vitamin
d level so most of the pth does not
begin to rise until the 25 hydroxyl
vitamin d falls below 30 nanograms per
ml or 75 millimoles however the
relationship starts to rise
exponentially once the vitamin d level
falls below the 15 or 20 nanograms per
ml
there's a more recent study
later on where there's a large
population was studied again it shows
this curvilinear relationship around 30
nanograms per ml which is sometimes used
as the cutoff point
as the sufficient vitamin d nutrition
one wonders whether the pthisa should
include vitamin d nutritional status in
establishing the reference range
although this is something that needs to
be looked into in the future
and
the next slide shows a recent study that
we undertook uh in collaboration with
diocerine and lab corp corporation where
there was a large cohort of people were
looked at where we had close to 330 000
pairs of 25 hydroxy vitamin d and in
this particular study it shows that the
cutoff is not
linear or
hyperbolic and it seems that the pth
level continue to suppress even 25
hydroxy vitamin d levels as much as 15
nanograms per ml so it's a debatable
item when is the sufficient
for us to consider pth as a reference
range
and in the lower graph shows the amount
of number of people who have levels with
the elevated pth level when the 40
nanograms is reached the number of
people with elevated pth level continues
to increase on the right two graphs i
illustrate the point that it is also age
dependent for the same level of 25
hydroxy vitamin d different age groups
will have different levels of
parathyroid hormone levels so one has to
age stratify as well as vitamin d level
stratified to find out what should be
the reference range for the pth having
said that
most people agree that
serum 25 hydroxy vitamin d about 30
nanograms should give us a reasonable
estimate of the normality of the pth if
we are establishing the reference range
and finally i want to touch one
important thing a number of years ago we
did a study looking at seven different
immunoreactive uh intact sorry irma
intact pthisas
in the diagnosis of overactive
parathyroid gland and all of them
performed reasonably well although area
under the curve range anywhere from 0.85
to 0.92 but in the clinical diagnosis of
primary hyperparathyroidism
it's not important which essay you use
as long as you use the intact pth assay
of course there will always be clinical
exceptions but suffice it to say that
most of the third and fourth generation
assets do perform very well in primary
hyperparathyroidism however they don't
perform as well in the cases of
secondary hyperparasites who are on real
dialysis
i want to switch gears to talk about
altered paraffin functional states the
first i will talk about some interesting
features about parathyroid gland this is
the smallest of all endocrine glands it
cause significant clinical
manifestations with only a two-fold
increase in its size for example
normal parathyroid gland weights weighs
only 40 to 60 milligrams whereas the
smallest adenoma that is known to cause
hyper calcium is 100 milligrams so a
small increase in size seem to cause
clinical manifestation you can compare
that with a thyroid gland for example
which weighs somewhere between 25 to 30
grams
in the abnormal glands you can have
adenoma hyperplasia or carcinoma
eighty-five percent are single adenomas
five percent are double adenomas ten
percent tend to be hyperplasias less
than one percent are cancer
but the weight of the parathyroid
adenoma ranges quite widely the lowest
possible
biologically causing hypercalcium is 100
milligrams to the best of my knowledge
the highest recorded parathyroid adenoma
is 45 grams that was actually from our
institution
in the normal glands it can vary from 40
to 60 milligrams but the highest gland
weight is about 160 milligrams
in most patients most individuals they
have four normal glands 84
but can range anywhere from 1 to 12 in
number and this becomes important both
in
patients who have failed parathyroid
surgery or those who have ectopic glands
or those who are on dialysis in whom
more than one gland may be present
the among the causes of hypercalcemia
primary hyperparathyroidism constitutes
52
cancer hypercalcemia is 42
the other cause is mostly due to vitamin
d poisoning or other ectopic production
of 125 dihydroxy so among the
hypercalcemia the most common cause in
the outpatient setting is primary
hyperparathyroidism
in most cases cancer hypercalcemia the
history will itself
give us the information that the patient
probably has femoral hypercalcemia of
malignancy
primary hyperparaphytium is the
commonest cause of hypercalcemia in the
outpatient setting
it is the second most common cause of
all hypercalcemias
third most common endocrine disorder
after diabetes and thyroid estimated
incidence is one to two hundred to one
to one in thousand depending upon which
populations are studied
incidence rises with age the average age
currently is about 62 years however in
certain parts of the world particularly
in middle east and india the age tends
to be much younger and we'll talk about
that briefly later it's more common in
women
the reason for which is not entirely
clear and it's more common after
menopause again one wonders whether
estrogen has a restraining effect on the
clinical manifestation of primary
hypothyroidism
there does not appear to be any specific
racial prediction
both blacks and whites in the united
states have similar incidents of
hyperparathyroidism
however the manifestation of the disease
differs between countries and between
geographic locations and based on the
vitamin d levels
i have summarized here the key
biochemical and clinical features
by definition
serum calcium must be elevated almost
always
this is always a debate exactly how many
serum calciums have to be elevated by
operationally over the years we have
mentioned that you should have at least
three consecutive serum calciums
measured at least one week apart over a
three month period
the exception to this rule will be
normal calcium hypoparaphiles which we
will discuss later
serum pth levels either are normal or i
preferably want to call it as
non-suppressed
two-thirds of the patients with mild
hyperparathyroidism tend to have
serum pth intact levels within the
reference range
uh serum 25 hydroxy levels depend upon
the geographic location vitamin d intake
they could be normal and very low
serum alkaline phosphates similarly are
quite variable in parts of the world
where parafire disease is much more
severe the serum alkaline phosphatase is
almost always elevated whereas in the
united states and western part of the
world where the disease tends to be much
mild the alkaline phosphatase may be
normal
bone mineral density is frequently low
but we cannot separate the age-related
decline in bmd from parathyroid hormone
however
measuring the forearm bone density has
been looked at as a possible
indication of pth effect on cortical
bone since it has more cortical effect
than the trabecular bone which is the
estrogen sensitive effect on the other
hand using the z-score could help you to
distinguish between the age-related bone
loss and that associated with overactive
parathyroid glands
the clinical manifestations depend upon
geographic location and the type of
patients you see age of the patients
vitamin d nutrition they can be totally
asymptomatic and of course they can be
quite symptomatic
hypercalcemic symptoms are quite common
in patients whose serum calcium level is
above 11.
many patients will have kidney stones
although in our practice it has declined
to about 2 percent which is no higher
than in the general population
fractures are also uncommon although in
certain parts of the world it's been
much more common than in henry ford
hospital experience there are several
genetic varieties which we will not go
into details
uh these uh primary hyperparathyroidism
can present largely as a sporadic which
is the usual one some patients present
as incipient or evolving
hyperparaphytism
there are five different four different
types of familial one there is an
isolated familial hyperparathyroidism
there's a familial
association associated with the jaw
tumor which is a genetic mutation
there's a benign familial hypocalceuric
hypercalcemia in whom the serum calcium
is stable urine calcium is very low
these patients do not respond to
parathyroid surgery
and obviously the well-known amine
multiple endocrine neoplasia types one
and two it is not type two a or three
which is associated with
neurofibromatosis but not
hyperparathyroidism
but eighty percent of the patients will
have sporadic hyperparathyroids
this has been a changing trend in the
incidence of overactive california gland
or hyperparathyroidism
there's a tenfold rise in the
parathyroid incidence after calcium
testing was recommended in kidney stone
patients back in 1934 by fuller albright
there was a four-fold rise after
introduction of biochemical screening in
the early 70s the so-called neo epidemic
then it has become stable in terms of
the incidents between the 1980s and
1990s
although the mayo clinic recently in the
90s reported there has been a decline in
the incidence of hyperparathyroids and
we have not seen if the henry ford
hospital experience nor other centers
that i spoke to have shown any decline
in the incidents i think the incidence
continues to be of the order of 1 in 200
in the population in general
it is important to recognize there are
two types of primary hyperparathyroidism
it was actually originally proposed by
dr lloyd in 1968 there could be a type 1
and type 2.
the type 1 hyperparathyroidism tends to
be more severe serum calcium is 12 it's
a short duration older age group bone
disease is more common stone disease
almost never present these have larger
tumors and they have more frequent
cancers in contrast type 2 has serum
calcium usually less than 12 milligrams
it is usually of long duration under age
group stone disease is the most common
presentation sometimes there is no stone
disease or bone disease and they tend to
have smaller tumors and parathyroid
cancers are
rare in this one
myself and dr parfit revised their types
more recently
type one we think is a true neoplastic
parathyroid disease called mitotic
control it tends to be continuous growth
these are the types of patients who tend
to get worse with time as we follow them
they frequently have osteoarthritis
fibrosis hypercalcemia is more market
the mutations in the parathyroid gland
are usually secondary and cancer
incidence is much higher
on the other hand type 2 which is most
likely a set point control related to
the calcium sensing receptor
and these patients develop hypercalcemia
and they reach an asymptote and remain
stable for extended period of time even
for 10 20 and 30 years
frequently they may have nephrologists
but still the overall incidence is about
two percent most often they are detected
during routine biochemical screening
mutations may be primary although the
proof of this has not been presented yet
our own data suggests that the initial
event probably is in the calcium sensing
receptor mutation and cancers are quite
low
so in summary primary
hyperparathyroidism in an earlier era
presented as a disease which was
euphemistically referred to as a disease
of the bones stones bones groans with
psychic overtones
over the past quarter century or at
least in the last 50 years the disease
expression has changed dramatically at
least in the west from a disease with
symptoms to a disease in search of
symptoms
and even in parts of the world we see
quite a bit
therefore
an interest has been expressed in the
traditional and non-traditional
manifestations of the disease i just
talked about the traditional on the left
side the non-traditional issues that are
being still being researched is the
quality of life issues do patients with
asymptomatic hyperpara
do really truly are asymptomatic or they
may have subtle symptoms that we don't
know how to measure
what about the bmd fractured
relationship because we do not have a
good data on the fractured incidence and
more importantly
the
reduction of the fractured incidence
following parathyroid surgery since it
will take a large sample size
there are some concerns about premature
death in the scandinavian and swedish
database on cardiovascular cerebral
vascular diabetes and hypertension
however in the mayo cities as well as in
our own cities we did not find any
increased incidence of cardiovascular
death
a study that we published indicated
diabetes is more common however
paired control study did not indicate
that diabetes is more common
malignancy is less common and the
question is how often this occurs we do
not know
and that's something that you need to
keep in mind
after 74 the non-traditional
manifestations became quite common
uh i just wanted to touch base uh
briefly about the relationship between
vitamin d and the tumor growth as i have
shown here between
1931-1945 parathyroid tumors seem to be
quite large when you move off all the
way to the right in the 2000s so for the
parathyroid tumor weight is much less
as you can see vitamin d was introduced
into the milk in united states as the
vitamin d nutrition improved the tumor
size declined and it remained stable
over the last several years therefore
the tumors above 500 milligrams are
uncommon
we did a comparative study between india
and the united states so if you look at
the 1995 1999 in india the tumor size is
much greater compared to the united
states the tumor size is much smaller
for a matched lower vitamin d levels
indian patients have much higher tumor
weight compared to the united states
patients indicating that either the
tumor is different type of mitotic
control or that the calcium deficiency
might be contributing in addition to the
vitamin d deficiency
again the prevalence of osteoarthritis
fibroids is cystica in the indian
population is much greater compared to a
very small percentage in the united
states in the henderford hospital
experience there were only about six
patients or close to 1500 patients seen
for the last 30 years
and there is a relationship between the
serum 25 hydroxyl vitamin d shown on the
x axis and the parathyroid gland weight
shown on the y-axis
it shows that there is the lower the
vitamin d the larger the tumor size and
this we have confirmed in the large
population of 1000 patients from the
henry ford hospital experience
and when you look at the
rock analysis it shows that the
tumors that are less than 500 milligrams
shown on the left side the main
determinant is the vitamin d whereas
tumors more than 1000 milligrams shown
in the right diagram vitamin d does not
appear to be important although pth was
important but that may be a collinearity
with the gland weight
it seems that the glands that weigh more
than thousand milligram probably are
neoplastic glands weighing less than
three 500 milligrams are probably set
point control as we talked earlier
uh it is frequently mentioned that in
the east patients may be diagnosed late
therefore they may have more severe
disease here is a comparison that i did
between brazil china india pakistan and
the united states as you can see
patients in india actually are much
younger compared to patients here so the
delay in diagnosis cannot be explained
simply on the basis of the pth and as
you can see pth is 10 to 20 times more
than what it is in the united states and
the duration of disease is no different
if any in the united states the duration
of disease is longer than in these other
countries where the disease presents
much more
vigorously
for the type 1 disease of the west from
the earlier era and the contemporary
primary hyperparathyroidism of the east
have rather striking similarity to
iodine deficiency and the megoidal just
as the iodine deficiency goiters
vanished when salt was iodized so has
the type 1 phpt vanished when vitamin d
was added to the milk at least in the
west however a new phenotype appears to
have emerged in the western side
and that is brings me to the question of
normal calciumic primary
hypoparathyroidism
because of the frequent measurement of
the pth in the evaluation of many bona
mineral disorders particularly
osteoporosis many patients have
increased paraffairer hormone without
the elevated serum calcium so by
definition these patients always have
normal serum calcium hence normal
calcium
they almost always have elevated pth
hence it is normal calcium hypopara
however they should have a normal serum
25 rocks vitamin d level normal urine
calcium normal alkaline phosphatase
almost always low bond density because
that's how they are being evaluated for
usually asymptomatic and they're
detected during osteoporosis
to conclude somebody has normal calcium
hyperparathyroidism one must exclude all
known causes of high pth that is calcium
deficiency vitamin d deficiency drugs
known to cause high pth
there's some paradox of the
parathyrectomy in hyperparathyroidism
clinicians are eager to recommend
parathyroectomy in mild disease where
the benefit is yet to be established but
shy away from parathyroectomy and
adrenal hyperparathyroids and where the
benefit is actually
probably immediate and indisputable
there's also some paradox about vitamin
d and calcium supplements and
hyperparathyroid patients clinicians are
very nervous about recommending vitamin
d and calcium as i have shown you that
these patients actually benefit by
calcium and vitamin supplementation in
the usual amounts that we give without
hyperparathyroidism
in fact restricting calcium and vitamin
d make the parathyroid disease even
worse on the other hand there's an
aggressive administration of the vitamin
d compounds in renal hyperparathyroidism
where the benefits of such therapy are
yet to be realized and many patients
probably require parathyrectomy when
they reach pth levels greater than
thousand picograms per ml
let me move briefly now to the secondary
hyperparaphytism
uh the key biochemical features here are
either normal or low serum calcium
depending upon the level of kidney
function it's almost always elevated pth
level since pth starts to rise as the
gfr declines
then frequently there's a low serum 25
hydroxy vitamin d level because of the
poor
health of these patients there's a
normal or low urine calcium it is
difficult to measure when the gfr is
impaired
usually elevated serum alkaline
phosphates particularly those who are on
dialysis
almost always have low bone density
because of long pth effect and usually
symptomatic and there is always a renal
failure vitamin depletion or both
just to recapitulate the pathophysiology
of secondary hyperparathyroidism
first there is a reduction in the serum
calcium obviously renal function
declines 125 reduction
there's a
retention of the phosphate which
indirectly stimulates the parathyroid
gland and all of these factors will lead
to the secretion of parathyroid hormone
there could be bone effects on
osteoarthritis fibrosis demineralization
fractures and bone pain and there is
also pth effect on nervous system
cardiovascular endocrine and immediate
so secondary hyperparaphrase image much
more complex than the primary
hyperparathyroidism that we just
discussed
this just illustrates it's an old study
but nevertheless an important study
where as the gfr declines as shown on
the x-axis pth level starts to rise uh
sorry uh 125 level starts to decline
when the gfr comes to around 60 mls per
minute so very early on in the renal
failure there's a decline in the sterom
125 levels which itself stimulates
parathyroid hormone
the calcium trial deficiency in second
hyperparathyroidism has effect on the
bone
probably affecting the bone blood
equilibrium of the calcium efflux it
obviously has an effect on enterocyte in
calcium absorption therefore frequently
patients have malabsorption of calcium
and finally it has an effect on the set
point of the parathyroid gland all of
which lead to increase in the
parathyroid hormone secretion so
calcitriol is probably key element and
phosphate retention is also an important
contributor
in contrast to the para primary
hyperparathyroidism where there is a
single adenoma in uremic
hyperparathyroidism it can have either a
polyclonal expansion and all glands are
enlarged called diffuse hyperplasia it
could have a multiclonal different
clonal arrangement so that they can get
modular hypoplasia and sometimes they
get monoclonal expansion of one of these
nodules and become monoclonal or
so-called tertiary which i will discuss
briefly
the adenoma in the secondary
hyperparaphyte behaves like primary
hypoparathyroidism
except it is much more severe
compared to primary hyperparathyroidism
the phases of this could be somewhat
similar to diffuse goiter of the graves
disease
toxic multimodal regulator of the
patients with
multinoduitas and adenoma is like a
toxic nodule those of you who are
endocrinologists can relate this but all
three varieties can occur in prima in
secondary hyperparaphytes and depending
upon the duration of renal failure
number of years ago we looked at the
pth levels in people with and without
the
presence of superior acid bone
resorption in the hand x-rays and as you
can see those who have no subterranean
erosion have a lower pth levels whereas
those who have superior absolution in
the hand accidents have much higher pth
but keep in mind the wide variation in
the pth level these assays were done
using the earlier intact assays with
more sophisticated assays
the difference may be much more and
almost most of them will have elevated
alkaline phosphatase by the time they
develop
visible
x-ray findings
more recently we looked at the effect of
secondary hyperparathyroids in an
african-american population as you can
see as a group african-americans have
more severe
hyperparathyroidism with higher pth
levels whereas the pth levels when you
move backwards to the less than 150
range they tend to have a dynamic bone
disease and in between they have a mixed
or moderate disease and many patients
are living longer on dialysis so they
may have
pth levels in the lower range by
developing aerodynamic bone disease
which tends to be problematic in
controlling serum calcium and of course
associated with fractures
the monitoring strategies have been
changed by the
doge guidelines recently and finally the
nephrology community have embraced the
importance of measuring pth as well as
administering vitamin d not the
metabolites but the vitamin d in order
to do that currently they measure pts
depending upon the region every three to
six months or six to 12 months or based
on the levels that one one needs to do
that
um brief word about the tertiary
hyperparathyroidism this is somewhat
misused most often
the key biochemical feature is that they
must always be hypercalcemic although
some people may disagree with my opinion
but the original definition of tertiary
hyperparathyroids was the development of
an adenoma in the background of
hyperglasia pth levels are always above
the thousand picograms per ml
they frequently have low 25 hydroxyl
vitamin d levels
uh urine calcium tends to be low because
of the renal failure they have high
alkaline phosphatase bone density is low
usually symptomatic and many patients
are either on esrd
dialysis or sometimes occasionally case
reports that prolonged vitamin d
deficiency can lead to the development
of hyperplasia and tertiary
hypoparathyrosis
let me switch to the final part of my
presentation is the hypoparathyroid
states
unlike hypercalcemia hypoparathyroid
states are somewhat less common
obviously they are detected when they
are hypocalcemic they have either very
low or undetectable pth or they have
very high pth depending upon
which type of hypoparathyroidism
obviously in idiopathic post-operative
hypoparaphytes and pth levels tend to be
low
when when i say low most of them are
below 15 picograms per ml or 10
picograms per ml
they are high obviously in pseudo
hypoparathyroid states because they are
pth resistant states uh remaining ones
as i outlined here
uh in esrd dialysis and prolonged
vitamin d depletion uh some people may
behave like
hypoparathyroidism because of the pt
inability to mount the pth effect
it could be due to pth deficiency either
absolute or post-surgical
idiopathic or agenesis it could be
relative depending upon the activating
mutations of the calcium sensing
receptor there are pth resist resistant
states which could be genetic or
acquired most often it is due to pseudo
hypoparathyroidism
sometimes magnesium deficiency and
vitamin d depletion can give you a pth
resistance state
uh rarely infiltrative disorders can
cause parathyroid hormone or parathyroid
gland destruction and then there are
some conditions where there is an
ineffective hormone action due to either
severe magnesium deficiency such as one
sees in patients with alcoholic
pancreatitis
chronic renal failure where the pth is
not able to keep immune and severe
vitamin d deficiency
symptoms are on the left side is the
symptoms related to the serum calcium
level mostly starts with tingling
numbness and twitching and muscle cramps
sometimes they can have carpal fetal
spasm and if the calcium level falls
below 60 milligrams per deciliter
seizures may ensure there are long-term
complications hence hypoparathyroidism
need to be treated
the most problematic ones are the
cataracts which are irreversible once
they develop and even more problematic
is the intracranial calcifications
that are irreversible sometimes these
patients may develop parkinsonian type
symptoms
soft tissue calcifications are more
common in pseudohypoparathyroidism
and skin disease with candidiasis is
common in idiopathic hypoparathyroidism
rare cases have been reported with
intractable heart failure when the serum
calcium follows below five milligrams
per deciliter they even get digitalis
toxicity
raised intracranial pressure and
papilloedema has been shown in severe
hypocalcemia
a simplistic approach from my
perspective is when one encounters
hypocalcemia one could easily from a
clinical point if you can figure out
whether it is pth deficiency or is it
vitamin d deficiency neuromuscular
symptoms dominate in pts related
hypocalcemia skeletal symptoms dominate
in
vitamin d related cataracts are frequent
in hypothyroidism
they are almost never seen in vitamin d
deficiency skin disease is more frequent
in pth related infrequent in vitamin d
related soft tissue calcifications and
intracranial calcifications are almost
frequent in the pth although rare cases
of vitamin d deficiency has been
reported but it's very uncommon
one could also look at the biochemical
and radiologic features to figure out
whether it is pth related or vitamin
related obviously serum calcium is low
in pts related but serum phosphate is
almost always high in pts related
hypocalcemia almost always low in
vitamin d related hypocalcemia
serum pth levels will be low or high
depending upon whether it is idiopathic
or genetic whereas it's always high in
vitamin d related with the exception of
hypophosphatemic osteomalacia
urine calcium is low in both conditions
simply reflecting the serum calcium
level radiologic features are usually
normal sometimes you can have
osteoarthritis fibrosis due to pth
effect on bone but not on the kidney
whereas here you will see the ricketts
osteomalacia or osteoporosis
one could also look at the pth and in
distinguishing these two types of
calcium
conditions if the calcium is low it's
usually hypoparathyroidism
if it is normal it could be calcium
sensing mutation magnesium deficiency or
the ineffective hormone if the pth level
is not elevated in the context of
hypocalcemia
if the pth levels are high one could
think of chronic renal failure vitamin d
depletion pseudo hypoparathyroidism
one can easily distinguish by creatinine
for chronic renal failure by the
phenotypic features of
pseudohypoparathyroidism
in cases of resistant syndromes
um
one other point that i want to make and
whenever one sees hypocalcemia following
surgery it's unclear whether it is due
to permanent hypoparathyroidism or
hungry bone syndrome the most important
distinguishing feature between these two
is the serum phosphate level when
measured on the day one or day two after
surgery it always rises following
surgery if they are likely to develop
hypoparathyroidism it always will be low
along with low magnesium and low calcium
uh low phosphate indicates that it is
hungry bone syndrome one could predict
that before surgery
and hyperphosphatemia following
parathyroid surgery or thyroid surgery
portends that they might become
hypoparathyroid permanently and these
patients need to be monitored more
closely whereas if they have
hypophosphatemia hypomagnesemia and
hypocalcemia tends to be temporary and
they respond very well to calcium
intravenous or oral
i would skip this slide because it may
be too complicated it's the
distinguishing between pseudo hypopara
and pseudo pseudo hypopara it's not
probably relevant because these are rare
cases
this is a picture of a patient with
pseudohypopathism showing short stages
obesity moon faces and as you can see
the patient on the the x-rays on the
right side show a symmetrical
decrease in the
in the fourth and fifth metacarpal
this is a patient of mine who i followed
for a number of years very unusual
showing the intracranial calcification
on the left is the intracortical
cerebral calcification on the right is
the cerebellar calcification an unusual
complication in postoperative since most
patients are
followed
followed
carefully therefore intracranial
do not develop
however in some patients if they are not
compliant with the treatment as this
patient has been for last 20 years has
developed unfortunately permanent
intracranial calcifications
in conclusion i have presented to your
physiologic and measurement
considerations
i presented to your pth measurements and
its evolution and vitamin d effects on
pth
we talked about phenotypes of altered
parathyroid states primary
hyperparathyroidism
secondary hyperparathyroidism tertiary
hyperparathyroidism
normal calcium hyperparathyroidism
various types of hypoparathyroidism
i hope my presentation has been
informative since there is some time
i'm going to go to a couple of slides
that might illustrate this is a patient
from india where it source on the left
that hardly you can see any bone six
months after parathyroid ectomy you can
see the deformed bone this is the most
extreme example of
osteoarthritis fibrosis cystica patient
with palpable and visible brown tumor in
the knee as you can see has a calcium
deposition and the large brown tumor in
the proximal tibia
patients will have pathologic fractures
shown on the left side with very
cortical thinning in a very small a
younger patient only 32 and the bone
biopsy shows that the entire marrow is
occupied by osteoarthritis fibrosa and
on the right side shows the typical
regular juicy spine even though there is
no renal failure
here is the visible parathyroid
on the on the right side you see two
patients the
patient is older sister is actually
shorter than the younger one because of
the severe osteoporosis in dialysis
patients you see extra calcifications
and the x-ray shows the
tumor calcifications
some patients with severe
hyperparathyroidism lose the terminal
digits here's a patient with loss of
terminal tufting called pseudo clubbing
and you can see the x-rays don't show
the terminal digit simply because all of
those x bonds have been completely
dissolved in the thumbs you can see
little fragmentation of the
bones
here is a simple example of widening of
the symphysis pubis is the best marker
for this and this patient when allowed
to continue develops severe austerity
fibrosis and
protrusio acetabulary of both females
over a period of five years
here is a typical example of regular
jersey spine and you can see at the left
bottom a calcified transplant kidney
this is the so-called superior erosion
it's the earliest marker pth effect on
bone there's a scalloping of the
area here that you can see this and this
usually seen in the second and third
middle challenges there's a tufting of
the
terminal areas of the areas here that
you see
sometimes you can see the
resorption of the clavicle from here to
there
is a marker of severe
hyperparathyroidism and of course bone
marrow fibrosis in the ex in the biopsy
one can do simple gem sheet in needle
biopsy to look at this bone marrow
biopsy
um i think i will stop here and i will
take entertain any questions i showed
you all this let me get back to this
slide
so thank you for your attention and i
will stop and hand over my things to my
control over to judy
for quite things too
thank you for that informative
presentation
i encourage our audience members to
submit their questions
before we get started on the question
and answer session i would like to
remind you how to submit questions you
can submit questions by typing them in
the q a box which can be found by
clicking on the green q a button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can
and
in the event that some perhaps did not
did not
hear or did not understand
submit questions by typing them in the q
a box which can be found by clicking on
the green q a button at the lower left
of the presentation window
okay we have our first question here
are there issues of quality of life for
these patients
i'm assuming uh
i'm assuming he's referring to quality
of life uh
related to high calcium the answer is
simple answer is yes it depends on the
which type of patient
dialysis patients have more quality of
life issues
compared to the primary hyperparathyroid
patients
and our next question is there a
relationship between para and
hypothyroidism
um interesting question to the best of
my knowledge not however i assume you
are talking about hyperpara
there is no relationship between
hyperpara and hypothyroidism because the
latter is much more common
however there is a relationship between
hyperparathyroidism and
hyperparathyroidism
about one percent of the patient with
hyperthyroidism
will present with concomitant primary
hyperparathyroidism but to the best of
my knowledge there is no relationship
between hyperparathyroid and
hypothyroidism however there is a
relationship between hypo parathyroidism
and hypothyroidism particularly in the
pth resistant states but not in
hyperpara
hope that answers my question
okay
uh listener says very informative can
you comment on the ability of current
pth assays to detect
truly suppressed pth levels
i.e
undetectable
that is an excellent question um
operatively we have decided at least at
henryford system if with the intact pth
assay the one that we use here if it is
most of them are actually if it is below
10 picograms per ml then you can be
reasonably certain in the presence of
hypercalcemia
that will suppress most often you get
below the assay limit of 7 picograms per
ml having said that including myself
have reported
several cases of undetectable
intact pth in honest-to-goodness
parathyroid adenoma and the reason being
that some of these pth molecules may be
post
transcriptionally translated one of them
being the phosphorylation serine 17
another is oxidative pth so there are at
least 10 cases of primary
hyperparathyroidism
in whom the pth level was undetectable
in some of them dilution has allowed to
unravel this and in many patients the
pth rises following parathyroid surgery
having said that
unlike other molecules such as prolactin
and growth hormone
pth is a straight chain 1 to 84 amino
acid there does not appear to be to the
best of my knowledge so-called hook
effect some of you who are
lab personnel can tell you uh so there's
nothing like hook effect in in the
pth
would you like to comment on the
relevance of the mass spectrometry based
intact pth assays especially in the
patients with secondary hyper
let's see hyperparathyroidism
now that's a tough question so
even though i spent the better part of
my life in the lab
i probably cannot answer because i do
not have much experience having said
that from a clinical point of view
however
it may not be that important because
most of the pth assays do reasonably
well the question comes up how much of
the elevated pth is biologically active
i think
in our own experience many of the newer
fourth generation pth assets have done
reasonably well
and in those circumstances where you
suspect that the pth
is biologically inactive you could look
at the serum alkaline faster as an
option to see whether there is about
independent verifiable biologic effect
of pth on bone uh i'm afraid that i
don't have a good experience with the
lcm sms with the pth i suppose it is
possible
would you expect any difference in
a second here would you expect any
difference in the pth versus 125 plots
if third generation assays that detect
the whole molecule were used instead of
second generation assays that recognize
certain c-terminal fragments
um
if i understand that correctly will
there be a difference in the
relationship
between the pth and 125 plots with the
third generation essay sorry um i may
have misdirected you the plots that i
gave you was the 25 in pth
uh it is possible uh i only had one
slide showing the 125 reduction of the
year all of the plots that i showed you
as the 25 versus pth
it is possible that the newer pth assays
might detect better because
patients with 25 drops of vitamin d
level below 15
only 50 percent actually have elevated
pth and it is unclear exactly why the
other 50 percent don't have elevated pth
conversely
why 50 percent have high pth so it is
possible i think your question is well
it's a good good question but i don't
think i have an answer
i have an answer
is there an environmental cause for
pediatric hyperparathyroidism
this listener says
do a lot of intraoperative pth
i'm assuming there is a
two-part question the
excuse me to the best of my knowledge
there are no environmental causes the
only environmental causes that are known
to cause hyperparaphytism is the
radiation-induced
hyperparathyroidism and that is after
external radiation or
you know radioactive fallouts there is
slight increase in the incidence of
primary hyperparathyroidism
uh head and neck radiation in the older
days was increased cause of
hyperparathyroidism
lithium is another cause of
hyperparathyroids i'm not that's not
environmental
um
if you want to you include vitamin d and
calcium as environmental then severe
vitamin d calcium deficiency ultimately
can lead to hyperparathyroidism
otherwise almost all of them probably
are genetically predetermined but we
just don't know which gene
is that i didn't get the last part of
the question so i'm afraid i have to
pass on to judy to see
uh was actually a comment so we'll move
on to the next um what are the
mechanisms that will affect vitamin d
absorption
that's also very good question
as many of you know or i'm sure have
experienced vitamin d is actually
absorbed in the sec the third and fourth
part of the duodenum and proximal
jejunum
so anything that affects that part of
the intestine will obviously interfere
with absorption the most modern era
a problem is the gastric bypass surgery
intestinal bypass surgery
post gastrectomy
rarely ulcerative colitis
type that affects the upper part so
anything that affects the
third and fourth part of the deodorant
and proximal jejunum and obviously
gastrectomy will affect
obviously people who are using
sunscreens will have vitamin d otherwise
the
the absorption is pretty good actually
even in those patients
the absorption is good if you give high
enough dose 25 hydroxy vitamin d
compound which is no longer available in
the west
absorbs slightly better than the vitamin
d 125 is slightly better than 25.
kindly address the relationship between
tth
rp and hypercalcemia
um yes good question um
obviously pthrp has the large
large homology between the intact pth
and the receptor p there are two
receptors for pth one and two
they bind to both receptors the affinity
depends on that
as i mentioned the downstream effect of
pthrp is to produce hypercalcemia having
said that
from a clinical point of view pthrp is
produced primarily by squamous cell
carcinomas particularly lung and
wherever the squamous cell is
so it can act as a pth agonist and
naturally will cause hypercalcemia most
of these patients have lower 125
compared to pth for some reason pthrp
does not stimulate one hydroxylase
compared to pth and they tend to have
alkalosis rather than acidosis where the
effect on kidney is slightly different
than pth as far as the hypercalcemia is
concerned the effects are similar
obviously related to the
pth receptor
could you explain what fourth generation
assays are and how they're different
than third generation assays
yes i don't know whether we can go to
this slide
um
if we can't uh
i think there was a this slide i don't
know that i can
yeah the the fourth generation assets
simply have the epitopes
between first to the sixth amino acid
because one of the cleavages in the pth
molecule is between seventh and eighth
molecule and later on in the after the
35th or 36th molecule so any assay that
has the epitope from one to six
preferably one to three
and has the
the arm assay with the two uh sandwich i
say for the carboxy terminal then it
will pick up
only the
1 to 84 not the 7 to 84. so fourth
generation you can say
will be the more proximal absolute
and that's commonly referred to as
biointact but of course there is a some
confusion about the what is third what
is fourth and so forth
is there any relation between
hypothyroidism and skin rash that can be
controlled with antihistamines
uh to the best of my knowledge no i'm
i'm not an expert in the hype
i'm assuming you're referring to
hypoparathyroidism if that is the case
most often it is related to the
autoimmune disease uh most of the
patients will be managed
with antihistamines but
frequently they would require topical
corticosteroids if you are referring to
hypoparathyroidism
i am not aware of the hypothyroidism and
the skin rash at least i'm not an expert
in that area
okay dr ral we have time for one more
question
uh is there a physique
on one second is
there a physiological reason
for why the 784 pth fragment would
inhibit whole pth effect on bone would
be beneficial
the
quick answer is we still don't know
exactly the mechanism the secretary the
dynamics of the 7 to 84.
there are some reports saying that 7 to
84 may be innately secreting hormone it
could be antagonistic to the intact
hormone it could be inhibitory hormone
uh i think future research is needed if
if true confirmed that 1784 is
inhibitory then it may have some
far reaching implications in clinical
practice
including control of hyperparathyroidism
and of course osteoporosis so
i think we have to stay tuned for that
one that's a good question though
unfortunately we are out of time i want
to thank the audience for their
interesting questions and participation
in today's event i would also like to
thank our sponsor diasauron for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through april 2015.
you will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
see you next time goodbye